the cell radio on your device operates
roughly like this from an initial idle
state it takes a couple of seconds to
turn on until it can start transmitting
that kind of latency makes for a sucky
web browsing experience so rather than
going back to idle state machine stays
on at full power for a certain amount of
time typically around five to ten
seconds
before dropping to an intermediate
low-power mode that uses less battery
than full power and has lower latency to
return to full power than the standby
mode if a new transfer is initiated the
radio will be promoted back to full
power mode and if nothing happens for
another period of time typically around
30 seconds to a minute it'll drop back
to standby the exact latency and tail
times vary between carriers and even
within carriers between states and
countries as they try to balance low
latency with a longer battery life based
on factors like cell congestion and
typical or prevailing Network conditions
so if the exact timings vary how do we
optimize our transfer frequency
ultimately it doesn't matter what the
specific timings are you just need to
understand that the network is going to
attempt to balance low latency with high
battery life for us when it comes to
planning out data transfers we'd really
like to be somewhere around here now if
we return briefly to the cell radio
state machine we know that every time we
perform a data transfer the radio will
stay active for at least another five
seconds of full tail time and anywhere
from 30 seconds to a minute at lower
power before it finally returns to
standby that means every time you
initiate a transfer you're powering the
cell radio up for at least 20 seconds so
let's take a look at how that affects an
app using the little cookie approach an
app like this can drain the battery
without even having to transfer much
data each of these small Peaks is an app
meaning it's analytics back to the
server in this case every 15 seconds
these larger Peaks represent
intermittent data transfers based on
user interaction for example they may be
viewing a restaurant listing or looking
at tomorrow's weather forecast beneath
it we've graphed how this affects the
radio state the blue shows active data
transfers the red the radio in full
power and yellow showing low power mode
the gaps in between if there were any
indication
when the radio is idle so while this app
is running what is the percentage of
time that the cell radio is able to go
back to its idle State